Claire what a absolutely wild episode
every single week I'm just like blown
away by this I love this show I've been
watching it for years and every week it
never disappoints but it's obviously sad
that you're not there anymore but now
for you having watched the episode
seeing it all played back how are you
feeling about your time on the show and
how everything went down
you know it's definitely a weird sense
of closure you know it's really living
something that happened eight months ago
to me and you know I had thought I
healed I thought I worked past it it's
definitely hard to see some of those
things see those emotions that I was
really really feeling I'm not somebody
who hides my emotions as you can tell
um but it's also just like
as of sad and devastating and brutal as
it was I was surrounded by people I love
my friends my family who want to support
me and
it's still just seeing myself and
thinking about the fact that I was part
of this and that I was there and that I
wasn't there for a long time but I was
gonna make sure I was I was shown and I
was there and I Was Myself and I Did It
My Way like
obviously the outcome was not what I
wanted but you can't live with regrets
on that stuff like they're tactical
regrets but
I went peace on that end oh well I love
that positive outlook that's a great way
to look at it but now we have to talk
about everything that went down
obviously so I want to talk about you
know you played your shot in the dark at
tribals so you knew something was up you
knew you were in trouble what was going
through your head before heading to
tribal were you already like yes I'm
playing it or are you like I'm gonna see
how tribal goes I was 100 playing it
like there was literally I I'm very like
analytical very logical and so for me
the rationale was this there were two
outcomes one Heidi doesn't flip Franny
rightfully will also vote for me because
why be against the crowd and I
need to play my shot in the dark because
then it's unanimous for me and that's my
one shot the second situation why I'd
still play my shot in the dark is let's
say Heidi does come around her and
Franny would then vote Josh Josh and
Danny would vote me I would play my shot
in the dark as insurance and then again
worst case Josh can't vote on a re-vote
so then it's gonna be two to one I'm
still safe so as much as I wanted to
like just make it an easier vote I was
gonna play my idol or not my idol my
shot in the dark like 10 times out of
10. gotcha I like that I like the
analytical side I feel like these
interviews allow me to get to know the
players a bit more than what's shown on
screen so I find it all so fascinating
um but quickly I do have to ask you I'm
surprised the showmans wasn't more of I
mean it was a target for people in a
sense but I'm surprised that wasn't like
people's initial thing get these people
out because we know how it goes with
Duos on this game I think it was the
initial thing right like we didn't go to
tribal until the third yeah so you have
like even though we're not going to
tribal
we are spinning our Wheels we are doing
oh yeah aired for every single challenge
who we're gonna vote and Matt was
definitely the main target it only
really flipped on me in those last few
days like it was just this revolving
door and it landed on me and Danny kind
of picked me but I mean I think it it
was as blatant as we were seeing but
like oh yeah first off it was really
felt like a genuine personal connection
like I was getting close with Heidi
while I thought
um but like people are getting close
individuals and like I'm sure they were
talking strategy but a lot of what was
so blamed about it was just like their
connection like it wasn't you know it
was as much as a regular Duo working
together if not maybe even a lot a
little less strategic
um so they were definitely a Target but
like Matt has become had become so
de-risked right you see actually people
who lose their votes are not actually
usually the ones that go home it's the
person next to them like Sarah Wayne
loses her vote Helen goes home even
though she doesn't have she has a vote
and so what's interesting about the
losing a vote is it frequently hurts the
people around you and with Matt you're
like he's not right he's not gonna vote
plus Danny now knows that Matt thinks he
has a real Idol so Danny's like yeah
this guy I got it I know exactly what's
going on I know that he thinks we have
trust he thinks he's safer than he is so
I get why Danny was like that's not
really a problem and then Franny was
like a challenge Beast like she's right
there next to Danny on every single
thing it was like the two of them were
really the like powerhouses and
challenges of like moving stuff doing
things so like I get that side of it and
like I wanted to work with them I
thought it'd be great to be the third
wheel on a showman so that was going to
be a bigger Target than me apparently
yeah
absolutely but speaking of you know
challenges and everything and you know
at tribal it was discussed about tribe
strength and what peop what that looks
like to people looking back having you
know not played the immunity challenges
I have two questions for you one was the
were those your decisions each time or
was it something that you know someone
pitched to you and was like maybe you
should sit out or was it a bit of both
so it's a really quick experience like I
thought yeah that you have like time to
strategize what you really get is you
get a quick description and then you get
10 seconds and just like let me know so
you just turn around and all look at
each other and everyone wants to play
you know people are all like literally
the first time I wanted to sit with
Matthew so once Matthew raised his hand
I was like oh like
I'll go but then like the second time
especially because it's easier than
putting a new person on the bench like
we turn around and you see everyone go
and then you see them start to look at
me and then you see let me go it's going
to be okay if you want to it's on like
let's do it again and then once we had
two set outs like it was a whole thing
and a lot of it was just like
looking at the challenge looking at what
I had did I think that me putting up a
fuss and saying no no let me play would
change the outcome of the game and if it
didn't I was gonna go with the flow and
if it did I would have said something
but those were three challenges that I
did not think I was differentially going
to win for my tribe gotcha and then
going back to the discussion of tribe
strength and the way that you were
defending you know everything that was
going on looking back at it now what is
does that still resonate with you or
would you define tribe strength as
something a little different now I
Define I've always defined tribe
strength differently I like am a huge
Survivor fan I'm a long game person I
know that like yes number one the
priority is making the merge right like
that's why everything keeps Danny around
we need somebody to get us to the merge
but to me like you see somebody's
incredibly strong teams they make it to
the merge if they don't like each other
they aren't loyal to each other they
crumble right like they just start at
each other and so for me when I was
thinking about a lion strength tribe
strength to me it was loyalty it was
rationality it was like logic and so I
also kind of assuming everyone else was
on the same boat in like the new era of
like this is the way
this is how you win a game
um but I think
I kind of underestimated how strongly
Danny and Heidi specifically Heidi cared
about tribe strength um but yeah I think
it's like there's so many ways to Define
it and to do the Brute Force thing is
such a cheap cop out because like the
challenges of one are lost on puzzles
not on Brute Force strength whatever and
I like no one can say that that's not
true and so for me there's things like
right like keeping morale up so that you
can get to that keeping people fed and
happy sleeping like there are things
that really are more important to me and
like at that point we had like as a
super fan I was like well we probably
have three more vote outs or so before
the merge we have two sit-outs right now
like we're not going to lose three in a
row like you're good if I sit out again
and I was literally like Heidi you hate
sitting out you were so upset that they
made you sit out if you put take me out
you're going straight to the bench dude
like yeah Danny's not going to the bench
Granny's not going to the bench you're
the bench one now and she was just like
I love all this Insight like I told you
it's so interesting to me but that's a
great way to put it and I love like I
loved your explanation of that so fans
were devastated that you left and you
know people are so upset including
myself that every week minus Bruce it's
been a woman going home but you know two
things
if you were given another chance to play
Survivor would you take it and what
would you say were your biggest
takeaways from your time on the show so
yes absolutely devastated and I think
one thing like I didn't know how I'd be
perceived I just could kind of make
myself a promise that no matter what and
this is how I live my life like I was
gonna do it my way I was gonna be
exactly what I am like I felt very well
represented like that is how I interact
with the world and it really is like
validating and lovely that people like
liked it
um yeah if I got the call right now I'm
leaving the zoom I'm flying to Fiji I
would pay I would really paid to play
Survivor again like there's not a single
thing that I love more and I have
unfinished business and I have a chip on
my shoulder that being said like my big
takeaways is like I think there are two
things first off like
some strategic changes I would have done
but the big one has been like and I talk
about this uh kind of in my like intro
video that's three minutes like
I have been a fan of survivors since I
can remember it's like one of my
earliest memories it's so important to
me and I've never applied before this
year I have thought about it I've
recorded myself I have videos of me at
18 practicing but I've never pressed
send because I had such a fear of like
failure and need for achievement and the
idea of rejection or not getting the
call or getting voted out first which I
did was so daunting to me that like I
didn't even take a swing and so the
biggest takeaway has been like I fell
flat on my face like right I did bad
things I didn't do that I didn't for me
winning would have been good
um
but I'm here and I survived it eight
months later I'm like thriving I have
friends my life still goes on and then
there's like a lock to me this ability
to like fail openly fail freely take
more chances and like it has allowed me
to get out of my head and be like I'm
more than like checklists I it doesn't
matter it's okay if I look stupid in
front of 10 million people I can now go
to that yoga class and try the hard pose
because whatever yeah it's been so
reaffirming and it's been just like
really a lovely like freeing moment and
I even re-watching myself get voted out
I like check my vitals and I was still
there and I was like
Life Goes On
wow that is such a great Outlook you're
such a positive light and such a
positive person and that was like the
best answer I could have ever imagined
that was beautiful and I feel like that
I need to take that advice I don't know
if I need to go on Survivor but I need
to take that advice so hopefully you
don't have to go through what I went
through yeah but it really has been like
it's a real mindset shift that is like
yeah so great
oh well that's amazing and you know
although I'm devastated let's manifest
maybe you coming back one day we would
like to see it we need Redemption
um but thank you so much Claire for
chatting with me today and yeah enjoy
the rest of the season so lovely thank
you so much for chatting with me you're
amazing